bonjour a tous un peu nous annonçait il
ya quelques jours la date du d'accueil
ou d'abeille ou d'ici la conférence des
développeurs d'apple qui a lieu tous les
ans au mois juin et cette année elle
aura lieu le 4 juin
je vous ai fait une vidéo dessus pour
vous en parler et qu'est-ce qu'on n'a
pas appris peu de temps après qu'ils
allaient faire une offre qui note le 27
mars rien et choisis au hasard que ce
soit la date la thématique c'est super
intéressant on apprend plein de choses
et on devine vraiment la continuité de
la stratégie de conquête d'apple et on y
va maintenant
c'est quand même dingue le 27 mars ça
vous rappelle rien si ça vous fait un
petit tilt ou pas je vais vous éclairer
tout de suite si vous n'avez pas capté
le 27 mars c'est la date à laquelle
huawei présente cp 20 ep20 pro c'est
cette date qu'a choisi apple pour parler
d'éducation et ça à mon avis c'est tout
sauf anodin mais on va en reparler vous
allez voir d'ici quelques instants
ç'a donc lieu hall in tech college price
a school à chicago dans l'illinois
quelques médias invités triés sur le
volet ont reçu leur carton d'invitation
avec dessus une jolie pomme le logo
d'apple quelque chose qui a été dessiné
à la main il ya un slogan qui très clair
les steaks fils tripp partons en
excursion donc là clairement on voit que
c'est une invitation au voyage
une invitation à la créativité à la
découverte
le parcours initiatique le rêve il ya
vraiment tout une thématique qui est
hyper forte et qui est vraiment dans la
création dans la créativité et on
souffre il écrit joignez-vous à nous
pour découvrir les nouvelles idées
créatives pour les enseignants et les
étudiants
saluant plus dans une université donc il
est très clair que cette keynote d'apple
se destine vraiment à l'éducation aux
étudiants aux enseignants mais pas que
au grand public c'est pas le premier
coup d'essai d'apple en 2012 y avait
déjà une keynote qui avait été fait sur
la thématique de l'éducation pourquoi en
2018 apple revient effectivement avec
une date sur la thématique de
l'éducation apple cherche à être
présents à différents niveaux de la vie
scolaire que ce soit dans la vie
scolaire au début de votre parcours
scolaire
lorsque cet étudiant et même le corps
enseignant et 100 m justement à une
autre question pourquoi chicago
il faut savoir que la ville de chicago
s'est lancé dans une vaste opération
pour apprendre le code informatique à
cinq cent mille élèves
selon tim cook je cite la programmation
est une compétence essentielle dans le
monde du travail d'aujourd'hui
donc on va très clairement qu apple à
désintérêt à venir draguer le monde
étudiant le monde enseignant à
l'utiliser comme une thématique forte
pour pouvoir a placé deux nouveaux
produits de nouveaux services et en plus
faire le bien
parce que quand on parle d'enseignement
on fait forcément lui bien on ne fait
pas que vendre des produits les
identifiants tout cas quatre points
essentiels qui sont vraiment très forts
pour apple et on va les décortiquer
ensemble le tout premier point c'est la
date le
27 mars c'est pas du tout une date qui
était choisi par hasard c'est
effectivement le jour de la présentation
du p 20 ep20 pro normalement pv night de
huawei les smartphones qui sont attendus
déjà depuis quelques mois
il faut savoir qu initialement on
s'attendait à ce qu'il soit annoncé au
mwc à barcelone
sauf que huawei n'a pas fait à ce moment
là probablement à cause de la
présentation de samsung la veille de
l'ouverture du mwc où ils ont présenté
les galaxy s 9 et s9 plus ça aurait été
effectivement dangereux de présenter les
p 20 et peu d'impro p20 light en même
temps quasiment en même temps que
samsung tout simplement parce qu'ils ont
été reléguées au second plan et qui
n'aurait pas été la star à ce moment là
l'idée de le faire un mois après à paris
c'est un vrai sens sauf qu'au final
c'est apple qui vient un petit peu leur
couper l'herbe sous le pied alors
forcément bauer ont une couverture
médiatique
ces smartphones sont vraiment attendu
pour voir si le p 20 et surtout de pépin
pro sera le photophone de l'année 2018
mais en attendant ils vont quand même
leur piquer une sacrée couverture
médiatique
il faut savoir qu'à être que huawei
s'est donné pour mission de détrôner
apple et samsung au niveau des
smartphones pour l'instant c'est pas
gagné il continue de se battre est
d'ailleurs pas qu'au niveau des
smartphones
que ce soit au niveau des tablettes
soient nouveaux ordinateurs huawei
fabrique vraiment d'excellents produits
mais pour l'instant c'est relativement
difficile pour eux de se placer au
niveau des opérateurs
ils arrivent à gagner des parts de
marché en france et sont quasiment à 10%
de parts marché
mais pour arriver au niveau de samsung
et au niveau d'apple il ya encore un peu
de boulot donc là ça paraît très clair
qu'apple peut leur mettre un petit coup
de coude dans les dents en leur disant
vous avez vu le 27 mars c'est pas
uniquement vos dates ont des présents et
va vous faire de l'ombre
le deuxième point essentiel c'est la
thématique la thématique de l'éducation
n'est pas une thématique choisie par
hasard alors ils n'ont pas sorti de leur
chapeau
c'est pas la première fois qu'apple
parle d'éducation mais dans une période
où apple rencontre un petit peu des
déboires avec des ventes d iphone qui
sont un petit peu moindre un même si
effectivement leurs appareils continuent
à bien se vendre même si apple quatrième
trimestre 2010 est abattu son score
historique a vraiment des super résultat
non pas parce que les ventes des iphones
sont énormes mais tout simplement parce
qu'ils arrivent à se diversifier et
c'est toute la stratégie aujourd'hui
d'apple
parlant d' éducation ils veulent nous
faire un peu oublier
les problématiques de batteries
d'obsolescence programmée même si
effectivement ils s'en sont défendus et
que pour l'instant ils n'ont pas été
condamnées là dessus ils ont toujours
droit à la présomption d'innocence en
attendant ça entache un petit peu la
réputation
donc là on va parler d'éducation on va
parler de faire le bien
parce qu'effectivement dès lors que vous
voulez aider les gens à être éduqués à
mieux savoir coder et en leur donnant
des solutions pour mieux préparer leur
avenir avec des produits à bas coût
c'est effectivement un point extrêmement
fort et ça c'est vraiment un argument de
choc pour apple
le point numéro 3 j'en ai parlé il ya
quelques instants c'est la
diversification à peut effectivement
voit ses ventes au niveau des iphone
stagner voire légèrement baisser
l'iphone 10 n'a pas vraiment vraiment
rencontré le succès qu'ils attendaient
il continue à bien fonctionner ça
devrait y avoir trois nouveaux iphone
ailleurs tout ça j'en ai déjà parlé dans
une précédente vidéo ailleurs pouvait
les voir une des choses ici qui sont
très intéressantes mais en 2010 elle
ccif a été si bon ce n'est pas grâce aux
iphone c'est grâce à la diversification
et si cette stratégie gagnante qui va
continuer à mettre en place et à
développer apple avec tout un écosystème
et plein de produits alors effectivement
les tablettes et or disent pas quelque
chose de nouveau mais la organisait une
keynote à rien que pour ça sur la
thématique d'éducation ça veut en dire
beaucoup
d'autant plus que la et s'adresse
vraiment aux institutions qui vont
pouvoir vendre des produits en tout cas
espérer les landes les écoles les
enseignants les étudiants et les
familles en règle générale est le
quatrième point qui est un point
essentiel est là où on voit que la
concurrence est de plus en plus rude
même si effectivement on voit
qu'aujourd'hui la concurrence sur les
produits très haut de gamme
il y en a pas énormément il ya une
grosse grosse concurrence sur le milieu
de gamme et sur le bas de gamme les
produits monte petit à petit en gamme
soit des produits de one + 2 au nord on
voit effectivement y grappiller du
terrain et qui montrent de plus en plus
enviable sur le haut de gamme
il ya quelques marques y sont présentes
mais pas encore énormément néanmoins il
ya de plus en plus de marques qui font
parler d'elles avec de nombreuses
présentations de nombreux lancements
séquelles samsung a fait parler de lui
au mois de janvier avec la sortie du
galaxy à 8 et a8 plus là les s9 s9 plus
regardées produits d'entrée de gamme qui
vont sortir encore dans très peu de
temps et doit y avoir un homme neuf qui
va sortir au mois de septembre
donc les concurrents occupe vraiment
l'espace médiatique est très important
pour apple d'être de plus en plus
présents là où effectivement la parole
d'apple est assez rare à un certain
moment il faut qu'il devienne un peu
plus présent sans forcément occupé tout
le temps le devant de la scène
mais l'idée d'être présent sur 7 qui
note sur la thématique de l'éducation
c'est super mal alors qu'est ce qu'on
peut voir
comme produits et services mcs
effectivement comprendre la stratégie
c'est un point maintenant voir ce qu'ils
vont nous mettre en face c'est autre
chose
bien évidemment pour l'instant il n'y a
rien d'officiel donc ce n'est que de la
spéculation mais il est très clair qu'en
voyant l'affiché en voyant le dessin
avec cette pomme destinée avec un stylet
on comprend très bien tout de suite
qu'on parle de l'ipad
et quand on nous parle d'éducation quand
on nous parle de code de code
informatique
il faut forcément un ordi pour coder
donc à mon avis il va y avoir deux gros
produits qui vont être annoncées et qui
vont être lancés ça va être de l'ipad et
ça va être du macbook
alors côté ipad on devrait avoir à mon
avis deux produits je vous en ai déjà
parlé dans une précédente vidéo
on attend cette année un ipad pro x
c'est-à-dire un ipad borderless avec une
encoche une caméra trou dead space heidi
un meilleur style et mettrait clairement
se produire et ce tout et tout de suite
assez cher et sera pas forcément destiné
aux étudiants de par son prix plus aux
enseignants et aux artistes et aux
créateurs
on peut imaginer effectivement des
architectes pas mal de monde dans
l'univers professionnel par contre pour
le domaine étudiants apple devrait
sortir un ipad low cost des grands
guillemets en ipad moins cher
probablement à moins de 300 dollars avec
un stylet et ça ça pourrait être quelque
chose de tout nouveau et de vraiment
intéressant
on n'aurait pas le même style et qu'on
retrouverait dans l'ipad trop de 2018
mais un stylet qui ferait déjà très très
très bien la faire peut-être le style et
qu'on est déjà dans l'ipad pro actuels
on attend également la sortie d'un
macbook air un hack book air à moindre
coût un ordinateur apple low cost sur
des grands guillemets avec apple
un produit qui permettrait aux étudiants
d'avoir un produit apple à moindre coût
est ce qu'ils feront une remise spéciale
pour les étudiants pour leur permettre
de s'équiper avec des produits un peu
moins cher est ce que l'ordinateur aura
un prix pour tout le monde
un peu moins élevé ça reste à voir
entendant s'attend vraiment cette année
à avoir un macbook air est probablement
avec un écran retina
parce que sur ce terrain là il faut
aussi faire face à la concurrence vous
avez d'un côté microsoft avec sa gamme
surface et surtout google et ses
chromebooks qui fonctionne très bien sur
cette thématique de l'éducation apple ne
peut pas proposer des produits qui vont
être forcément trop cher s'ils veulent
être crédibles devrait aussi avoir une
annonce faite du point de vue logiciel
alors apple a déjà plusieurs logiciels
dans le monde de l'éducation avec itunes
ou course classroom ibooks store il
devrait y avoir pas mal de choses
dans l'éducation l'idée effectivement
celle qui note c'est pas de vous caler
un nouveau iphone c'est pas de vous
caler à nouveau au mode ça on en
reparlera au mois de juin et au mois de
septembre
l'idée effectivement l'acf adressé au
grand public et de parler d'éducation
dites moi vous que vous en pensez est ce
que vous vous êtes sensible à ces
annonces que pourrait faire apple est ce
que vous êtes sensible à cette
thématique de l'éducation est ce que
vous pensez que le fait qu'apple fasse
sa conférence dans une université saga
ne vote pas un petit peu l'université se
galvaude pas un peu le propos est ce que
ça vous paraît vraiment phase de dire
non non on fait une thématique par
rapport à l'éducation on l'a fait dans
une université parce qu'on s'adresse
directement aux étudiants directement en
corps enseignant est ce que pour vous
c'est un sens au long est ce que vous
trouvez ça choquant qu'une grande marque
comme celle là se retrouvent dans une
université pour parler directement de
produits de services qu'ils vont
commercialiser
mark et moi tout ça en commentaire parce
que c'est vrai que quelque chose d'hyper
intéressant à mon avis en france c'est
quelque chose qu'on risque pas de voir
arriver cette manière là j'imagine
difficilement à peu ou microsoft allait
faire une keynote de sueur du lancement
de produits du lancement de services à
la sorbonne où je ne sais où
ou henri iv ça me paraît très
relativement déconnant mais après tout
on sait jamais mark et moi tout ça en
commentaire comme d'habitude nous
mitonne laissé deux jolies pousse à vous
abonner pour soutenir mon travail puis
surtout pour en savoir toujours plus
parce qu'il va y avoir beaucoup d'infos
à la sortie de cette keynote bien
évidemment je vous en parlerai et on va
débriefer tout ça ensemble
on va également parlé des huawei p20
ep20 pro donc restez connectés d'ici là
soyez sages portez vous bien et
n'oubliez pas que vous sortir un maximum
de contenu toujours plus pertinent
toujours plus intéressante et si vous
avez des suggestions des questions et
tout ce que vous voulez les commentaires
sont là pour ça merci à vous très
bientôt vous embrasse son message était
ok
[Musique]